quelques minutes avant l'ouverture des
grilles devant le lycée la tension monte
c'est dans dix minutes bon ben on va
prier je stresse un peu normal mais en
vrai je pense que je l'aurais je pense
je pense que je vais avoir le bac
peut-être sans sion mais au moins avec
le bac avoir le bac 9 heures pile
l'équipe pédagogique affiche les
résultats les lycéens envahissent alors
la cour
des cris des rires la joie se fait
entendre molly siens désormais
bacheliers exulte
monsieur c'est admis ah oui là je suis
content même même mes amis l'ont eue là
c'est vraiment trop bien alors qu'est ce
que ça donne j'ai une bague du coup
consortium j'ai quand même eu c'est déjà
ça moi j'ai eu bac mention assez bien
là ça va oui moi aussi ont bien caché
bien travaillé
ben oui oui je sais pas qui sait quelle
puce récit cissé ou nous mêmes non je
suis fier d'elle
pas de fête pour les recalés et pour les
quelques élèves admissibles il faudra
attendre leur rattrapage et replancher
jeudi mais que ce soit pour le bac
général technologique ou professionnel
le taux de réussite est encore cette
année très élevé
89% donc on espère aller à 92 93 94
pourquoi pas à 100 donc voilà on compte
sur la solidarité entre les élèves et
puis l'entr'aide pour pouvoir les faire
progresser réussir là le dernier chemin
un chemin désormais différent élèves et
professeurs ont tenu à célébrer ensemble
ce moment c'est toujours une petite
émotion parce que chaque année on tisse
des liens avec les élèves et c'est vrai
qu'on a à coeur de les accompagner au
mieux et chaque année c'est vrai que
c'est toujours les mêmes sentiments on
est content parce que au moins on se
rend compte du travail fait durant
l'année
des cadeaux pour les professeurs et des
sourires sur les visages de ses ex
lycéens après les notions ces bacheliers
pense déjà à l'avenir